[bell]
Ernst, my good man.
Ah.
Two tins of the
usual, professor?
Indeed.
And I would like you
to meet my good friend,
and thorn in my scientific
side, Dr. Niels Bohr.
Hello.
An honor to meet you, sir.
Ernst, are you familiar
with Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle?
I can't say that
I am, professor.
Well, it states that the
more accurately we measure
the velocity of a particle,
the less accurately
we can measure its
position in space.
So you know exactly how
fast the thing is going.
Yes, but if we do, we cannot
also know where that thing is.
Does that sound logical to you?
No, sir.
EINSTEIN: Of course not.
And according to my
esteemed colleague,
the particle does not exist
at all until we observe it.
That makes absolutely
no sense to me.
EINSTEIN: Exactly.
Thank you, Ernst.
Shall we stop by
your butcher's as well?
Perhaps he has an
opinion on the matter.
Ha ha.
Very amusing.
Albert, the uncertainty
principle works.
It functions, and
it allows us to make
use of the quantum world.
The goal of scientific pursuit
should not be merely to make
use of the world around us.
It should be to understand
it fundamentally, no matter
what use it might have.
Albert, look out.
[car horn]
Just watch where
you're going, please.
Why should I?
Why should either of us?
According to you, if that
automobile was a particle
but we didn't see
it, it wouldn't
have been there at all.
We would be perfectly safe.
Automobiles aren't
subatomic particles, Albert.
EINSTEIN: Niels, it defies
common sense that the rules
which govern those
things we can see do
not apply to those we cannot.
[car horn]
I will not turn off my
brain simply because you've
decided the matter is settled.
Well, then, if you don't start
using your brain to observe
what's right in
front of you, you're
going to get yourself killed.